l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti visto morire
sono papi jv sono appena ripreso da tre
giorni di febbre a 40 non vedevo l'ora
di prendermi perché ho detto mi chiamo è
il primo gioco che posso fare che mi
metti un allegria pazzesca che può no
proprio no coke ragazzi siamo sul
geometri desse per la gioia di del mondo
è uscita la versione completa ragazzi
che non era ancora uscita e adesso ci
sono anche le monete che non so che cosa
sono io ti ammazzo la famiglia giuro che
ragazzi a parte gli scherzi non vedevo
l'ora di tornare sul lago prepariamo le
vostre voleva avere la febbre ancora 40
per qualche giorno proprio lo sto
desiderio apporto è tutto ragazzi
l'ultima volta su riuscito a fare le
madonne sull'ultimo livello non so
perché c'era quello ovviamente io per
guardare a sinistra sbatto la faccia
giusto credo di aver visto una moneta la
gamma che servono le monete hanno messo
le monete che non ho idea di che cosa
fossero serva bene qualcosa
attualmente si comprare le figurine non
so non me ne frega no come si fa a
prendere possibile ascoltami java
gianfrancesco se io l'ho chiamato
gianfrancesco devi ce la puoi no la
madre incubata non è possibile devi
capire una cosa io ti ho chiamato
gianfrancesco per un motivo
ok porca put a non è questo il motivo
ero contento nel mio letto l'altro
giorno che guardavo my little pony porca
[ __ ]
niente devo saltare tu stai mai di
temponi non saltano e per quel iv gamma
questa musica quanto mica è [ __ ] cioè
pazzesca
le musiche visto gioco raga sono
fantastiche sì
a none parti contrapposte phil jackson
three sterminati che sto facendo
non so che cosa ma va bene così allora
ragazzi tutta in un botto basta
vincerò adesso vado a vendere panini
vanno a vendere panini scusate se non
c'è
raga io ho già capito che adesso in
avanti geometri da snodo più avanti è
possibile ma perché cazzo sono sti cosi
lampeggiano ogni tre secondi non capito
ancora vabbè concentrazioni la moneta
non la prendono e sono più rare nelle
sfere del drago secondo mese cosa
ok ok ok bene così siamo nei pantaloni
coi cosi e wine bar folk in ciò non
sempre sognato di fare sta roba lì cosa
bounce il gioco mi ha visto saltare mi
ha dato bounce quando ho preso questo
gioco qui hanno messo delle telecamere
in camera mia per vedere che saltavo non
voglio sapere
va bene uguale comunque ok ok eccolo
ragazzi non sono mi ricordo dove sono
morto potrei incazzarmi potrà incassare
ero molto qua sì se la supposta regala
sul posto è uscita sul posto perfetto
sai dovete la infilo gianfrà idee più
grossa di te bravo bravo gianfrano
bravissima bravo l'amore come capendo le
monete non è possibile prenderle
monetari che se va beh ci mettiamo pure
mia nonna con le lasagne non so quasi
quasi era meglio mia nonna con le
lasagne già voci tutti all'ippica che
secondo me meglio cosa che gesù è
diventato un centro anti gravitazionale
perfetto se qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegarmi come cosa per quando barun e
mi fa un piacere perché non ho capito
cos'è lo giuro veramente sì ma va bene
così ma supposta forziamo scene di
quello che appena successo ci prova
uguale no no no no no io capovolto non
riesco a giocare ragazzi nocciola non mi
si incrocia al cervello di più sempre lì
stavo già sbattendo la faccia di
prepotenza nel giusto perché parlo
no no no stermino la stirpe madonna del
piano piano piano perfetto allora da
adesso in avanti mi devo concentrare
scusatemi legato concetto se non
annuncia farò mai più
sì sì l'ho superato merda o dio
sì sì sì ria
no cosa
[Musica]
il giorno in cui ho scelto di giocare a
questa roba potrò fare altro tipo
picchiare orsacchiotti non lo so è una
roba inutile e inutile sto gioco
ragazzino non c è un ora che sono su un
[ __ ] livello ma possono andare avanti
da questa roba ok ok ok ragazzi se no io
io potrei fare del male fisico a delle
persone ok specialmente chi ha creato 97
96 mi preme anche per il culo dai
maledizione 30 minuti all'ora mezz'ora
in mezz'ora per un [ __ ] livello di me
ci sono anche le monete in stack agata
che non voglio neanche immaginare da
sean penn cosa cazzo piange che ti kill
un cazzotto che mi diventi così che
bella che è bello che vengono mela cotta
di quanto fosse bello il menù è che ho
fatto proprio bene per i quadratini a te
le frecciate belle o mio dio nome non è
corto distacco è finito il tempo ragazzi
e ci dobbiamo il prossimo video no no
cento del blog dai facciamo una bella
che abbiate ha chiesto già chiesto alla
divertente alla competente ato1 ok io mi
piace la musica in partenza solo che non
ho capito cosa sto giocando a fare
questa merda cosa comunque a pause
rischio kay
ok non mi sembra tanto difficile questo
non si parla a fare che tanto muoiono
con questo non dormo abbiate fatto
veramente cosa cos'era quella merda
comunque allagata per questa roba
bellissima di musiche quadratini sua
mamma e punta va bene comunque un po di
cose belle e veramente voglio fare la
domanda seria ai creatori di sto già si
si è fatta
non che il no non voglio sapere come va
bene così
ok ok a primo tentativo a caso cosa sì
sì a caso bene così ho fatto una cosa
che non farò mai più quindi io vinco
adesso mi do al basket cinese
ok ok mio dio la propaggine ragazzi ma
caso a caso
gianni verga tutto è tutto nero nonché
tu che va bene così la moneta non ha
prenderò mai nella vita ma non ne frega
una sega proprio metterseli prenderle
tutte mette a servizio nel curare bene
bene no no al contrario al contrario 72
per cento luciani verrò mai prima
ragazza suo livello e tipo per chi fa
beatbox roba tipo
[Musica]
sì non ero proprio io ragazzi ho sentito
che mi va bene anche un 76 per cento è
vero questo ho sentito proprio io lo so
che volete che sia così
quindi posso concludere tranquillamente
anche così vero ve lo dico ragazzi
perché potrei averne per un bel po
diciamo quindi vorrei passare la mia
adolescenza in modo gli infelici giusto
non così forse perfetto sì ciao ragazzi
io sto rifacendo calmi si perfetto
perfetto dove domenica 9 che andava
dov'è che vi deve incazzare che non mi
ricordo più strambo andrà il contrario
ti giuro che capovolgono ha sede visto
gioco se non riesco si no ci mancherebbe
altro ci mancherebbe all'impossibile 20
regalo le mie carte di poche ma quelli
di traumatico affanculo [ __ ] tiro
fuori da questa merda basta non ci posso
più fare chiudo non ce l'ha potrò mai
più fare il jumper prova un attimo prova
a vedere l'amica mo riesco a primo
tentativo a farlo tu no seriamente
apartitica giusto perché non
non si può fare non ce la posso più fare
sto andando in esaurimento
che cazzo di musica di merda ma che è il
livello dei pony dei pony stronzi pure
se dobbiamo aggiungere la musichetta dei
giochi per bambini un gioco dove tirare
sti testate al mondo intero per averci
giocato colpa di tutti merda è sta roba
veramente la presa per il culo
allucinante tanto sto facendo non si sa
come lo fate domande perché io parlo se
ok ho premuto resta supporto per sé
bensì al contrapponiamo mettere al
contrario anche mia nonna non sono fate
voi c'è giusto per vedere cos'è estero
hexagon force fatemi so cos'è sto un po
di merda bello complimenti
c'è una freccia qui cosa serve non lo so
sono morti center o mio dio mio dio ho
fatto 4 per cento e va bene così almeno
a 10 su 10
sì sì già fatta
9 per cento 99 va bene 9 va bene
comunque ragazzi a parte tutto è stato
un bellissimo ci sarà anche dei livelli
personalizzati ho visto oltre a ste
cagate di livelli pubblici nel prossimo
episodio ci provo spero che video vi sia
piaciuto perché non è che mi ha dato
tutta sta felicità sai dove darà infilo
quella proprio cioè la forma giusta che
il video vi sia piaciuto perché
volentieri me ne sarei stato nel letto
con la febbre ma proprio non so perché
c'è la pagina di facebook no terminati
vi faccio del male fisico se mi arriva
la risposta la metto su facebook spero
che ragazzi se il video è piaciuto ma si
fa sotto il commento mi piace anche a
voce di facebook e camerano tratta in
descrizione sostenitori city tecnici non
posseduto fa affanculo mi è caduto anche
il telecomando per ragazzi